the start of a new day in local AMA in
the Democratic Republic of Congo behind
the village is dense swampland satellite
images have revealed the existence of a
peat bog here in the forest biologists
say it's one of the most important ever
discovered that's why a team of British
and Congolese scientists have embarked
on a joint research project getting to
the peat bog involves an arduous hours
long hike through the swamp everything
is soaking wet
English geographer Simon Lewis has been
surveying here for years trying to
better understand the development of the
bog which began forming tens of
thousands of years ago made up of
decomposed plant material the peat held
some surprises for the researcher this
is Pete so this is the partially
decomposed plant matter that is a store
of carbon so this is now sampled every
50 centimeters and this is 2 meters to 3
meters deep but what is the surprise is
that we thought that Pete here would be
maybe 50 centimeters maybe wanted me to
maximum and actually we've got much
deeper people so that suggests that
potentially we haven't done all the work
yet but potentially there's even more
carbon stored on this side of the Congo
River the scientists now calculate that
the bog is far bigger and deeper than
they originally estimated the peat layer
is up to 6 meters thick in places and
covers an area about the size of Great
Britain that's why maintaining the area
is so important for the environment as
you see there is the rounding the forest
so the forest is also storing the carbon
stoking the carbon so it's double
stoking carbons above ground biomass
turning it to carbon and also the
underlying deposit and if you wipe this
forest does we are double x releasing
the carboard more carbon in the
atmosphere the forests of the Congo
Basin are under ever-increasing pressure
similar primeval woodlands and Asia have
already disappeared and deforestation is
now also a threat in this part of Africa
illegal loggers are taking down more and
more trees meanwhile the government is
granting licenses some according to
environmental groups under dubious
circumstances but as local populations
grow so does the need for arable land to
plant cassava for instance farmers like
Valentina Gobbo say they have no choice
to acquire new fields they say they have
to drain at least some of the Moors we
have to maintain a balance between
preserving nature and survival yes we
need alternatives to deforestation but
it's not that easy there are no projects
in place to help people pursue other
livelihoods that's why the environmental
organization Greenpeace has stepped in
to support the scientists financially
and logistically and to teach the
villagers more about why environmental
protection is vital a government
official explains the difficulties the
country is facing we would have to
provide aid to the people here so they
don't take resources from the forest
such projects cost money money the
government doesn't have that's why we
need the financial support of the
international community the activists
say it's imperative to develop a
strategy that provides financial support
for the entire region otherwise the
Congolese authorities will continue to
permit logging which will eventually
lead to the release of vast amounts of
sequestered co2 'the internet we need to
find international solution is not only
to help these countries protect these
primeval forests but also to further
study the peat bogs in order to protect
them because they contain huge amounts
of carbon there are some 30 billion tons
of carbon trapped in there that's the
equivalent of three years of total
global emissions from coal oil and gas
combined
even gasp the scientists have finished
for the day but it'll take months to
record and analyze all the data they've
collected providing more insights into
one of the largest carbon reservoirs on
the planet